اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
ساعه اخباريه احتفائيه من العربيه نبدا
باهم عناوينها
رئيس مجموعه فاجنري يؤكد محاصره باخموت
ويطالب القوات الاوكرانيه بالانسحاب من
المدينه
روسيا تحذر الدول الغربيه من ان ارسال
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا سيوطيل امد الصراع
متحدثه الخارجيه الصينيه تصف الولايات
المتحده باكبر مصدر للتهديد النووي في
العالم
على الهواء العربيه تحتفي بالذكرى العشرين
شاهده لا تغيب عن توثيق الاحداث عربيه
وعالميه
في التالي من مارس عام 2003 ولدت الشاشه
الاهم والاولى في فضاء قنوات الاخبار
العربيه والدوليه 20 عاما مشاهدينا
7300 يوم اكثر من 175 الف ساعه بث اخباريه
وبرامجيه رافقتكم فيها شاشه العربيه داخل
منازلكم ومقرات اعمالكم ومجالسكم عشرون
ربيعا تغير فيها وجه العالمين بحق اذا
مشاهدينا عقدان شهد فيهما وجه السياسه
والاقتصاد تغييرات كثيره على مستوى العالم
وخلال تلك الاحداث ظلت العربيه شريكا في
خارطه تلك الاحداث الدوليه اهلا بكم
مشاهدينا الى هذه التغطيه الخاصه بمرور 20
عاما على انطلاق قناه العربيه قبل البدء
في هذه التغطيه نتابع معكم مجموعه من
الاخبار لتطورات السياسيه حول العالم
وجه رئيس مجموعه
خطابا الى الرئيس الاوكراني في مقطع فيديو
مصور نشره على قناته في تيليجرام طلب فيه
بالانسحاب من مدينه باخموت مؤكدا ان
المدينه محاصره بالكامل
انني اخاطب رئيس اوكرانيا فلو ديمير
زيلينسكي عزيزي فلو ديمير لقد حاصرت وحدات
فاجنر العسكريه بخموت عمليا لم يتبقى سوى
طريق واحد مفتوح امام القوات الاوكرانيه
الكماشه تزداد احكاما انهم يقاتلون لكن
حياتهم في باخموت في خطر دعهم يغادرون
المدينه لانها محاطه عمليا
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ان صيغه
السلام التي قدمها الرئيس الاوكراني
لا تهدف في الواقع الى تسويه سلميه للصراع
اضافت الخارجيه في بيان بانزلنسكي يواصل
الترويج لما يسمى بصيغته للسلام والتي في
الواقع لا تهدف الى احلال السلام ولكن الى
تشكيل تحالف معاد لروسيا
وصفت المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه المتحده بانها اكبر مصدر للتهديد
النووي في العالم كما طالبتها بان تعيد
التفكير بدقه في سياستها النوويه وضعت
المتحدثه واشنطن بمسؤوليتها الخاصه
والاساسيه بشان نزع السلاح وان تقلل من
دور الاسلحه النوويه في سياسه الامن
القومي بالاضافه الى ضروره ان تتخذ واشنطن
اجراءات عمليه مجديه للحد من المخاطر
النوويه وفق قولها
في مؤتمر صحفي المشترك قال الجيشان الكوري
الجنوبي والامريكي انهما سيجريان تمرين
درع الحريه وهو تدريب لمركز القياده يقوم
على المحاكاه بالكمبيوتر في الفتره من
الثالثه من الثالث عشر الى 23 من مارس
اذار لتعزيز قدراتها الدفاعيه وللاستجابه
ايضا
ستجري جمهوريه كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات
المتحده تدريبات درع الحريه لتعزيز الموقف
الدفاعي المشترك وذلك لمده 11 يوما من 13
الى الثالث والعشرين من مارس تم تصميم درع
الحريه لتعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه
والاستجابه للتحالف من خلال التركيز على
السيناريوهات التدريبات بالاضافه الى
اشياء مثل البيئات الامنيه المتغيره
وعدوان جمهوريه كوريا الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
بالاضافه الى الدروس المستفاده من الحروب
والصراعات الاخيره
قالت القنصليه البريطانيه في القدس
المملكه المتحده تحث على اجراء تحقيق في
مقتل فتى فلسطيني قرب قلقيليه في الضفه
الغربيه وعبرت القنصليه في حسابه على
تويتر عن اسفها بسبب عدم الاستقرار
المستمر والخسائر في الارواح في جميع
انحاء الضفه الغربيه كما قررت دعوتها الى
ضبط النفس عند استخدام الجيش الاسرائيلي
للذخيره الحيه
انخفض مؤشر اسعار الغذاء العالميه الذي
تصدره منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه التابعه
للامم المتحده للشهر الحادي عشر على
التوالي في فبراير ليبلغ انخفاضه 19% من
المستوى القياسي الذي سجله في مارس اذار
الماضي في عقاب الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
اقلت منظمه ان مؤشرها الذي يرصد اسعار
السلع الغذائيه الاوليه الاكثر تداولا على
مستوى العالم بلغ 129 نقطه في المتوسط
الشهر الماضي انخفاضا من
130.6 اعشار في يناير وهذه هي اقل قراءه
للمؤشر منذ ايلول 2021
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل ايضا
العربيه تحتفي بالذكرى العشرين شاهده لا
تغيب عن توثيق الاحداث عربيه وعالميه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد حاضي الملف
اليمني على شاشه العربيه بحيز كبير من
التغطيه والاهتمام منذ انطلاقتها عزز ذلك
او من ذلك احداث اليمن عام 2011 ومع عقبها
من احداث حتى دخول ميليشيا الحوثي الى
صنعاء عام 2014 وانطلاق عاصفه الحزم ثم
اعاده الامل في 2015
ومعنا هنا في الاستوديو بدر القحطاني
الكاتب الصحفي في جريده الشرق الاوسط حياك
الله بدر معي في هذه الساعه الاحتفائيه
بمناسبه مرور 20 عام على تاسيس وبدايه
قناه العربيه كصحفي كيف رقبت العربيه ابرز
محطات العربيه خلال عقدين مضت في الحقيقه
نبارك للعربيه اولا كاصحافيين وزملاء
وكانت عشرين عاما من الالق والركض المستمر
الذي توج حقيقه
مهنيه ومصداقيه عاليه حتى اصبحت العربيه
معيارا لدى صحفيين انا دائما عندما اتواصل
مع الصحافيين في الميدان المراسلين حتى من
الزملاء في وسائل الاعلام الاخرى معيار
القصه الناجحه هو ان تطرح في العربيه
العربيه ليست مصدر للاخبار فقط وليست منصه
عميقه للتحليلات بل هي ايضا مراه لاعمال
الصحفيين الناجحه الذين لا تتوانى العربيه
ولا تخجل من عرض وطرحها ونقاشها اذا كانت
تستحق بكل مهنيه وهذا بحد ذاته يعتبر
بمثابه جائزه للصحفيين وهذا جزء من دور
العربيه التنويري الذي تمارسه منذ 20 عاما
نحن كصحفيين شبان
تابعنا العربيه كمشاهدين ثم تابعناها
كزملاء في المهنه ومنخرطين
وتعتبر العربيه ليست محطه التنويريه في
البدايه كانت تمارس وما زالت التنوير
ولكنها الان اصبحت
تنافس نفسها على المنصات الرقميه والحضور
المتميز رقميا طيب اردنا ان نتحدث عن
تجربه العربيه كما تفضلت بها خاصه في ملف
صعب في ملف اليمني هذا الملف الذي تسبب او
كان ملف صعب جدا بالنسبه لكثير جدا من
القنوات في المنطقه ولذلك بسبب ربما حاله
الانقسام الاقليميه نعم حاله الانقسام
الاقليميه التي
ضغطت على المشهد بسبب هذا الملف وصعوبته
كيف كانت تغطيه العربيه للملف اليمني وفق
رؤيه بدر القحطاني اعتقد انه كان هناك دور
مهم لعبته العربيه فيما يتعلق بتبسيط وشرح
المسائل اليمنيه للمشاهد العربي وايضا طرح
القضايا المعقده جدا على اليمنيين انفسهم
واعاده روايه القصص اليمنيين انفسهم ولكن
من وجهه نظر عربيه وهذا امر مهم جدا لان
هناك الكثير من المحلين اليمنيين الذين
يطرحون وجهات النظر المختلفه اليمنيه
وايضا هناك محلي مهتمين بشؤون المنطقه
سواء من الاقليم او حتى من خارج الاقليم
ممن يتعلق بالصوره الاكبر للصراع الملف
الايراني
ملاحكات التي كانت تجري وما زالت في
الولايات المتحده هذه التغطيه البانوراميه
وانا لا اقصد فقط برنامج بانوراما طبعا
لكن هذه التغطيه البانور واحد من من اهم
البرامج يعني على شاشه العربيه والبرامج
العريقه واللي دائما ايضا حتى تناقش الملف
اليمني وكثير من ملفات الدوليه احد
المحطات المهمه في اليمن هي كانت عاصفه
الحزم عام 2015 انطلاق العمليات العسكريه
والعربيه كانت باول قناه واكبت طبعا بدايه
هذه العمليات العسكريه وانتبهتمامك بهذا
الملف اكيد كنت متابع طبعا تلك الاحداث
تلك الليله يعني تحديدا منذ ذلك الحين
وحتى اليوم ما الذي طرا من تغيرات في
تغطيه العربيه للعمليات العسكريه والاحداث
في اليمن في الحقيقه العربيه تميزت ايضا
باجراء اول حوار مع الرئيس السابق عبد ربه
منصور هادي وهذا يدل على حرص العربيه على
السباق الصحي بينها وبين وسائل الاعلام
الاخرى وفي الوقت نفسه كان هناك نضج كبير
جدا فيما يتعلق بالتغطيه كان هناك اتزان
كانت هناك منعطفات مره بها او مرت بها
الازمه اليمنيه نجحت العربيه في اختبار
التوازن كانت منصه للجميع لكل الاطراف
المتزنه التنويريه المعتدله التي كانت
تريد الخير والسلام لليمن وان كانت
متصارعه وهذا يحسب العربيه الحقيقه ايضا
هناك مساله كنا نتحدث عن بانوراما مساله
التحليل مساله تحليل مهمه جدا لازمه معقده
وازمه مركبه لانها اصبحت مع الوقت مجموعه
ازمات في داخل ازمه واحده وهذا بالتاكيد
لعب دورا في تنوير الشارع العربي والشارع
اليمني بطبيعه الحال وهذا يجعلنا نحن
كصحفيين دائما على اطلاع مستمر والعربيه
ليست الشاشه وحسب انا دائما انتصر لزملاء
في منصات التواصل الاجتماعي في العربيه
النت ومختلف الامور انا اتذكر ابان
الاحداث السوريه ربما نخرج من اليمن قليلا
كان هناك حساب خاص للعربيه او من اوائل
الوسائل الاعلام التي خصصت حسابا لمتابعه
الاخبار السوريه وكان حسابها مميزا وهذه
اتذكرها جيدا كمتابع كمهتم بقضايا المنطقه
هذا الامر يجعلنا جميعا نفخر ونتمنى
للعربيه كل التوفيق والنجاح وعقبال 100
سنه
اليوم شكرا السيد بدر القحطاني الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي شكرا
شكرا لك للعربيه وللقائمين عليها
وشكرا على تطوركم وتفاعلكم ومواكبتكم
السريعه لمساله
التطورات الاعلاميه وايضا التقنيه
والتكنولوجيه من خلال النت ومن خلال مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
ومخيل هذا كله يعني انا اقول هذا عملا ان
شاء الله باذن الله يكون بيتكلل بالنجاح
ويوفر للقارئ العربي والمشاهد العربي
الاجواء الاعلاميه او القناه الاعلاميه او
الوسيله الاخباريه المحترمه
لم يجب الشان الخليجي يوما عن شاشه
العربيه التي تابعت اهم وابرز الاحداث
الخليجيه طوال عقدين من الزمن من السياسه
الى القضايا الاجتماعيه وليس انتهاء
للثقافه والرياضه نتابع
[تصفيق]
تجد اليوم في الامارات مرحله التصويت
النهائيه لانتخابات المجلس الوطني
الاتحاديه الاعلان عن الاسامي ستكون في
العاصمه ابوظبي في المركز الرئيسي
سجلت سلطات العمانيه سبع وفيات جديده بسبب
اعصار الشاهين
[موسيقى]
اصلاح البنيه التحتيه والوقائع اعصار
شاهين الذي ضربها عمان
[تصفيق]
كيف ترى سلطنه عمان مشهد الدول او الازمات
في المنطقه هناك ازمات صعبه معقده وشائكه
[تصفيق]
هذا المسجد يمتد عمره لاكثر من
1400 عام
سنكون معكم من العلا على الهواء مباشره
بيان علا الذي سيتم توقيعه في هذه القمه
المباركه
البدايه من الكويت الواقعه في اقصى شمال
الخليج العربي من الكويت ننتقل الى
السعوديه حيث تربطهما حدود بريه من
السعوديه ننتقل وعبر حدود بريه تتجاوز 60
كيلومترا الى قطر البحرين هي الاخرى تقع
في الخليج العربي وتعد ارخبيلا ومن
البحرين ننتقل الى الامارات التي لديها
شريط ساحلي على الخليج العربي من الامارات
تنتقل الى سلطنه عمان الواقعه في الجزء
الجنوبي الشرقي من شبه الجزيره العربيه
في دبي الى استوديو العربيه هنا في العلا
السعوديه حيث عروس الجبال استطاع هذا
المجلس ان يتجاوز كل هذه العقبات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ترقب يعيش شارع الكويتي وبرامج انتخابيه
مكثفه لنبدا من هذا الخبر ماذا لديك اكثر
يقول بانه لا يسوغ لاي او ان يكون ممثل
الامه
تغلق صناديق الانتخاب ولكن اثرها سيبقى
طويلا اليك خالد
انطلقت اليوم السبت الانتخابات النيابيه
والمجالس البلديه في البحرين طبيعتها
وحجمها قبل فتح الابواب كانت هناك عديده
وحشود من الناخبين سير العمليه الانتخابيه
الى هذه اللحظه وجود كثافه كثيره في جميع
مراكز الاقتراح
مع
انتهاء العالم العربيه 360 ترصد لحظات لا
تنسى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مباراه دراماتيكيه حبست الانفاسه
بتحدياتها واحداثها وتفاصيلها
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا بهالمنام ينضم الينا الكاتب
الصحفي عبد الله الجنيد اهلا بك سيدي عبد
الله معنا في هذه التغطيه وكل عام وانتم
بالف خير
واحداث البحرين كانت حاضره بقوه في تغطيه
العربيه خاصه خلال تلك
المرحله الصعبه التي عاشتها البحرين بين
عامي 2011 و 2012 كيف ينظر البحرينيون
بصوت عامه الى الدور الذي لعبته العربيه
في تلك المرحله
عسى الله
مشاهدي العربيه وكل عام وانتم بخير
بالتاكيد كانت العربيه
القناه النافذه باحساس البحريني في تلك
اللحظه وكانت كذلك شريكا في عمليه
نقل الصوره والحدث بكل شفافيه ولذلك
العربيه تعمقت انتماء في وجدان الانسان
البحريني
قبل وتعززت اكثر من خلال رسلها ومتابعه
للاحداث الموسفه في البحرين استاذ عبد
الله حياك الله معي من جديد يعني ربما
تابعت الشؤون الخليجيه خلال يعني عقدين من
الزمن ربما كانت التدخلات الايرانيه في
الشؤون الداخليه لهذه الدول هي احد
الملفات الساخنه والمهمه ايران كذلك ايضا
كانت حاضره في حرب ناقلات في
19 لاتفاق النووي ايضا الذي وقع عام 2015
كيف
رصدت كيف تابعت ايضا هذه الحقبه والمرحله
الزمنيه والتعامل العربيه ايضا مع تغذيه
هذه الاحداث المهمه في الاقليم
اهلا وسهلا اخي نايف بالتاكيد
الحضور كان بشكل شخصي او من خلال الكتابه
مع العربيه
ومتابعه العربيه لتلك الاحداث بالتاكيد
كانت
منبره مهما في ايصال الروايه بدقه
الحرص على الحياديه قدر الامكان
ونتمنى ان تستمر العربيه في تطوير تلك
المبادئ
وبالتاكيد
نقل كذلك عن العربيه ما صنعته من يعني خبر
عبر وسائل الاعلام فكانت
اداء الايصال الراي الاقليمي اقليميا
وكذلك نقل الصوره على المستوى الدولي في
في كل هذه المراحل المعقده سواء من خلال
عمليه استهداف امن واستقرار للمنطقه او
كذلك من ما ذكرته يعني سواء حرب الناقلات
تهريب السلاح الى
اليمن
يعني
رفع مستوى التوتر في البحر الاحمر في بحر
العرب فهذه كلها احداث مثلت احدى الهواجس
او ربما بعض الناس في الاعلام الدولي
فاكملت قنوات مثل قنوات العربيه قناه
العربيه نعم نحن دكتور عبد الله الجنيد
وكل عام وانت بالف خير واتمنى ان
تكون معنا في مساحات اوسع شكرا لكم يا اما
كنت مع الكاتب الصحفي عبد الله الجني
تحياتي
اعتقد ان قناه العربيه ملات فراغا كبيرا
يعني من المهم
للمشاهد وخاصه في العالم العربي ان تكون
هناك منصات اخباريه
مميزه
تحمل رؤى ووجهات نظر مختلفه ويبقى الحكم
للمتلقي اتكلم في العالم العربي لو لم تكن
العربيه موجوده لكان هناك اعتقد فراغ كبير
لكان هناك فراغ كبير صعبا يملا
مشاهدينا الى دبي وفقر في الاقتصاد مع
جميع الارحابيب كل عام وانتم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا بالطبع يتمتع اقتصاد
السعوديه بما كان متقدمه محليا وعالميا
فالمملكه عضو في مجموعه العشرين واكبر
اقتصاد في العالم العربي واكبر مصدر للنفط
والعضو المؤسس والرئيس لمنظمه
الدقائق المعدوده لهذه الفقره الموجزه لا
تكفي لاستعراض مكانه اقتصاد المملكه
بالطبع ولكن سنحاول جاهدين استعراض ابرز
واهم المراحل والاجراءات والاصلاحات
الاقتصاديه والماليه التي ساهمت في تطور
اقتصاد المملكه والتي تبعناها اولا باول
ورصدناها لحظه بلحظه على مدار 20 عام
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم الى هذه التغطيه الخاصه من
العربيه حول رؤيه السعوديه 20 30 ان نادين
هاني معكم من الرياض
وانا لارا حبيب من دبي حيث نرافقكم على
مدار ساعه كامله للاحاطه بمختلف تداعيات
هذه رؤيه على المواطن السعودي واقتصاد
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
صدرت اليوم رؤيا السعوديه عشرين ثلاثين
وابرز الاهداف التي وضعتها رفع مساهمه
القطاع الخاص في الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
الى 65% ورفع نسبه الصادرات غير النفطيه
للمملكه الى 50% من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي الامير محمد بن سلمان يعلن ان
طرح ارامكو سيكون مرحله اولى فقط تتبعها
مراحل لاحقه لطرح الشركات التابعه للشركه
الام القابضه ولكن المرحله الاولى ستكون
ضخمه بكل المقاييس حيث سيكون الطرح العام
الاكبر في التاريخ
البيانات الاوليه تتكلم من صندوق سوف يكون
او يسيطر على اكثر من 10% من القدره
الاستثماريه في الكره الارضيه وعصب بث
العربيه الامير محمد بن سلمان عكس مؤشر
سوق الاسهم بالسعوديه اتجاهه ارتفاعا
لمكاسب باثنين ونصف
[موسيقى]
عالميا ايضا وصلت المملكه تدعيم حضورها
بقوه بين اوساط المؤسسات الاستثماريه
العالميه وكبار المستثمرين في مختلف
المجالات عالميا وذلك باطلاق مبادره
مستقبل الاستثمار في نسختها الاولى عام
2017 بمشاركه اكثر من 2500 شخصيه رائده في
مجال الاعمال من اكثر من 60 دوله حول
العالم شاهد المؤتمر اطلاق عدد من
المشاريع الاستثماريه مثل مشروع مدينه
نيوم كما شهدت اطلاق صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه
ببرنامجه للفتره من 2018 ل 2020 وتميزت
هذه المبادره بحضور الذكاء الاصطناعي
متمثلا في تواجد الروبوتات مثل صوفيا التي
يتذكرها فريق الاسواق العربيه في تغطيته
السنويه لمبادره مستقبل الاستثمار
مبادره مستقبل الاستثمار تجمع اقطاب
الاستثمار والاقتصاد في الرياض محمد بن
سلمان يطلق مشروع نيوم
مدينه نيويورك
[موسيقى]
خارج السعوديه بحجم يصل الى 100 مليار
دولار
قدره استثماريه ضخمه جدا مستهدفه بحجم 500
مليار دولار
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه بلغت ثلاثه ونصف بالمئه هذه
البيانات
[موسيقى]
ايضا من ابرز الاحداث الكبرى يلي خصصنا
لها ببرامج الاسواق العربيه مساحه واسعه
من المتابعه والبث المباشر هي احتضان
الرياض لقمه مجموعه العشرين في نوفمبر
2020 قمه افتراضيه عبر تقنيه الفيديو
انذاك بسبب اغلاقات كورونا وهي اول قمه
لمجموعه العشرين تستضيفها السعوديه كاول
بلد عربي يستضيف القمه وهو الامر الذي توج
رئاسه المملكه والمبادرات المطروحه من
خلالها بالنجاح
[موسيقى]
وفي شهر ديسمبر من كل عام نتابع الحدث
الابرز اقتصاديا وماليا في السعوديه والذي
يستنفر فيه قسم الاقتصاد بكل قوته وادواته
حيث يواصل فريق العمل التحضيرات المسبقه
لايام المتواصله وربما اسابيع لتقديم ادق
التفاصيل وافضل عرض ممكن لارقام الميزانيه
سواء من الرياض او في استديوهات العربيه
هنا مع انتقاء المتحدثين وضيوف الحدث
الاهم بعنايه احد افضل ما قدمه فريق
الاسواق العربيه من ابداع بمفهوم الاعلام
المتخصص والمزود باحدث تقنيات الجرافيكس
والاخراج بمعنى الكلمه هو ميزانيه 2017
مشاهدينا اهلنا بكم في متابعه خاصه تتجدد
في هذا الشهر من كل عام نستعرض فيها اهم
ما حدث لاكبر اقتصاد في المنطقه هذه المره
لن نتحدث كالمعتاد فقط حول ارقام
الميزانيه التقديريه لعام 2017 والارقام
الفعليه لعام الحالي 2016 بل نتطرق لعده
سنوات مجمعه تصل لخمسه اعوام
[موسيقى]
وميزانيه السعوديه لعام 2022 كانت حاضره
بقوه ضمن اولويات فريق الاقتصاد في قناه
العربيه خاصه ان المملكه سجلت اول فائض في
ميزانيتها العامه منذ عقد باكثر من 100
مليار ريال مع توقعات بان يبلغ الفائض في
ميزانيه السنه الحاليه 90 مليار حيث
استفادت المملكه من ارتفاع اسعار النفط
فضلا عن النمو في قطاعات غير نفطيه
كناتج كنتائج فعليه والملموسه من تنفيذ
برامج رؤيه 2030 للتنوع الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
نبدا مع ارقام ميزانيه العام الجديد حيث
جاءت الارقام كالتالي ايرادات عند تريليون
ومئه مليار ريال فيما بلغت النفقات عند
تريليون
و14 مليار ريال وفائد متوقع بقيمه 16
مليار ريال وهذا الفائض يشكل حوالي
0.4% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للمملكه
[موسيقى]
العامه والشركات التابعه له
مشاهدينا هذا بالطبع جزء بسيط من متابعات
قسم الاقتصاد لاهم الاحداث ورق قرارات
الاقتصاديه التي شهدت تطور اقتصاد المملكه
على مدار السنوات الماضيه لا يمكن اختصار
بدقائق قليله ولكن نعدكم بالمزيد من
المتابعه الدقيقه لكل الاحداث المهمه في
السعوديه وحول العالم عوده الان مجددا الى
نايف واحمد لمتابعه هذه التغطيه الخاصه
شكرا لك لا ارى اذا مشاهدينا فاصل ونعود
استكمال هذه التغطيه معنا
[موسيقى]
من اليوم بعيد
حياتي
جمله الصفحه
اختار عيش حياتك
نختار متعه جالكسي
متعه القرمشه تغمرها متعه كل منتدى الرياض
الثالث للاعمال الانسانيه سنتحدث عن
اوكرانيا سنتحدث عن الازمات العالميه
قد تكون بديل عن التسلح او عن الاسلحه
[موسيقى]
يا سيد اخي
مع منتهى الرمحي السبت 11 والنصف على شاشه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
او فاكر
مقضيا كلام خد اكسرا وسلم من جديد
شرفنا
معاك اخوك سعيد
[موسيقى]
اعلان رفع رايه التحدي لتغيير وجه المنطقه
لتكون اوروبا الجديده هذا ما اكده ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان بعد
اعلان رؤيه السعوديه 20 30 وهو ما تعزز
بمشاريع كبرى كان البواكيرها في اعلان
المدينه لاكثر حداثه على وجه الارض نيوم
العربيه مشاهدينا كانت حاضره لحظه بلحظه
لرصد هذه التحولات التاريخيه في السعوديه
العربيه هي منبر عربي مهم جدا
وقناه يتابعونها السعوديين والعرب بشكل
مكثف ونعتقد انها رسالتنا سوف تصل
للسعوديين والعالم العربي من خلال
[موسيقى]
بعد الاعلان وفي اللقاء وقناه تحقق ما
يزيد عن تريليون ونصف ريال اذا استهدفنا
هل سبعين بند رؤيه هي ما فيها شيء ولا
فيها برامج تنفيذيه
[موسيقى]
في رؤيتها لعام 2030 تؤمن السعوديه بان
ثروتها الحقيقيه تكمن في مجتمعها وافرادها
ريال 500 مليار ريال او اكثر في عشرين
عشرين عشرين ثلاثين سوف نصل الى ترليون
ريال سعودي في هذه الرؤى قد وضعنا
الاقتصاد السعودي خطوه على الطريقه الصحيح
حمايه للاقتصاد من ناحيه القدره الحكوميه
على خلق ايرادات لا تتاثر بسعر النفط
[موسيقى]
لدينا فرصه ننتقل الى جيل
او طريقه الحياه
من التقنيات فكل عناصر نجاح موجوده هل شيء
عظيم وشيء جديد واهم عنصر لدينا هو الشعب
السعودي
الفرق الذي سوف يكون في يوم كازون
داخل اليوم مثل الفرق بين هذا الهاتف وبين
هذا الهاتف
[موسيقى]
ليوم وجهه المستقبل مشروع جديد اعلن عنه
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
هو المشروع الاول من نوعه عالميا
والمستثمرون شركاء في صياغه انظمته
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
دوله تريد ان تنوع الاقتصاد هذا المشروع
يستهدف تسع قطاعات اقتصاديه بكرا تنتظر
خطاب ودها من المستثمرين خالد العمري
العربيه كيف يجب النظر الى هذا المشروع
العملاق قياده سموه العهد طرحت مشروع حديث
تماما في نوعه كيف سيؤثر مشروعا يوم على
وضع المملكه اقليميا وسياسيا هذا ليس فقط
مشروع اقتصادي وليس فقط مشروع تنميه بل
مشروع حضاري يدمج مجتمعات عده جبال
والرغبه والاراده الشعبيه القويه
[تصفيق]
بتصاميم مبهره بدات ملامح اليوم في
السعوديه بالتشكل حيث يترقب العالم حتى
الان ثلاث مدن ابهرت الجميع عند الكشف عن
تصاميمها ذا العين
ثلاث مدن تم الاعلان عنها في نيوم ورصدت
العربيه لحظات هذا الاعلان بكل تفاصيله بل
وكانت معكم على ارض اليوم
[موسيقى]
اعلان صندوق الاستثمارات العامه السعودي
عن استراتيجيته او وجود الصندوق راح يساعد
ان شاء الله على جذب هذا الاستثمارات ورفع
الثقه
مليون وثمانمئه الف وظيفه في خلال خمسه
سنوات قاطره استثمارات تنمويه اعلنا ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان عن
تصاميم مدينه لاين في نيوم
[موسيقى]
ثوره حضاريه كبيره جدا
اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عن انشاء مدينه نيوم الصناعيه
اوكسجون
اماكن التغيير اماكن التحول اماكن سطر
التاريخ فيها بلحظات الالهام هذه طبيعه
المكان الذي ستشكله اكس الافكار في هذا
المكان ستغير العالم
اعلان الامير محمد بن سلمان رئيس مجلس
اداره اليوم طبعا عن انشات روجينا هذه
الوجهه العالميه للسياحه الجبليه الجديده
جبال البحر
الاحمر لجذب انظار العالم
عالميه فريده طبيعتها ساحره وتقنياتها
فائقه شموخ يسكن قمم جبال نيويورك مرحبا
فيتروجينا
جبان نيو
من الخبر ينضم الينا نايف الدندني المحلل
الاقتصادي حياك الله معنا في هذه التغطيه
الخاصه والاحتفائيه بالعربيه بمناسبه مرور
20 عاما على انطلاقه العربيه يمكن في
محطات مهمه اقتصاديه كثير مرت فيها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بعد اعلان رؤيه
2030 انشاء مدن اقتصاديه كبرى ايضا كذلك
حتى التعامل المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع
اسواق النفط التقلبات التي حدثت ابرز
المحطات برايك التي تعاملت معها العربيه
محطات الاقتصاديه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وابرز المشاريع ايضا حتى كذلك ما
هي الاسس والمعايير التي رصدتها للتعامل
العربيه معها
مبروك للعربي اولا مبروك للعربيه اولا
ومشاهديها بعقدين من التميز والاحترافيه
نتمنى لكم كل التوفيق فيما يتعلق بالمحطات
الحقيقه في خليني اتكلم التغيير الحقيقي
شاهدناه من بعد عام
2015 الحقيقه تغيير هائل في
بكام في كامل مناحي الحياه الاقتصاديه
والنفط احد اهم المجالات اللي شاهدنا فيها
تغيير
الحقيقه استراتيجي ومهم في سياسه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اذا تكلم عن بالمجمل في
المحطات الاقتصاديه احنا شايفين انه عمليه
التغيير التي تشهدها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الان هي اعظم عمليه تغيير تشهدها
دوله في القرن 21 ايه حتى الان عمليه
ديناميكيه تاخذ طابع تنفيذي
طابع رؤيه والحقيقه بخطوات متسارعه وتسابق
نفسها بعض بعض هذه المستهدفات الحقيقه حتى
قبل
اللي يحدث في السعوديه هذه الورشه العمل
العملاق الهائله
يعني واضح للعيان
اين ستتجه واين المستهدفاتها وانها
الحقيقه جالسه تخطي خطه ثابته لتحقيق
المستهدفات الاقتصاديه اعود لك على موضوع
الاهم على مقاطعتك هنا لكن
من وجودك معنا قدر الامكان وكما وصفت
السعوديه قد تحولت الى ورشه عمل كبيره منذ
اعلان الرؤيه في عام 2016 لكن الملاحظ
ايضا ان هذه الرؤيه حتى وان كانت اقتصاديه
والتنمويه في جوهرها الا انها لم تهمل
ابعاد اخرى تحدثنا عن اهتمامها بالرياضه
بالثقافه بالتعليم وهذا ايضا ما يجعلها
رؤيه شامله وهذا يعد من عناصر قوتها بحسب
ما يقول المراقبون والمحللون ما رايك
بالتاكيد هي رؤيه شامله لدوله لتغيير في
في كامل مناحي الحياه سواء الاقتصاديه
الاجتماعيه
القانونيه في كامل مناحي الحياه احنا
شاهدنا انه الان الاستراتيجيات جالسه تنفذ
في الجانب الاقتصادي في الجانب السياسي في
الجانب
في جانب الطاقه في جانب الجانب الاجتماعي
في الجانب العدلي في التشريعات في الانظمه
في في موضوع الاستثمارات في المشاريع
الكبرى اي يراد للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
ان تكون في عشرين ثلاثين الجانب الرياضي
مثلا الجانب الرياضي جانب جوده الحياه كل
هذه الحقيقه شايفين احنا تغيير هائل في
هذه الملاحي وفي هذه المجالات
والنتائج تتحدث عن نفسها وواضحه للعيان في
في
اما ان الى المستهدفات او بعضها تحققت
بالفعل ممكن اسواق النفط كانت يعني حلقه
مهمه ضمن
يعني المراحل الاقتصاديه والنفطيه كذلك
التي مرت بها السعوديه منذ 2014 عندما
انهارت اسعار النفط هوت من 140 دولار الى
30 دولار تقريبا
بعشرين عشرين جائحه كورونا وانفراط عقد
اوبيك بلس وصولا الى مقاومه الضغوط
الغربيه لزياده الانتاج ورفض طبعا الانتاج
في زياده الانتاج بل على العكس تماما
تخفيض الانتاج هذه المراحل كيف يمكن
توصيفها باختصار سيدنا نايف
الحقيقه محطات مهمه جدا 2014 كان انهيار
لاسعار النفط وشاهدناها من مستوى ال140
دولار الى مستويات الثلاثين دولار في
الثلاثينات هذا الحقيقه اتى مع
متوافق مع الرؤيه عام 2015 2015 ايضا شاهد
حدث مهم اللي هو اتفاقيه باريس للمناخ
التي حولت اتجاه مجموعه كبيره من دول
الصناعيه الكبرى الى انها تاخذ
استراتيجيات
ضد النفط وضد استمرارها في الوقود
الاحفوري المملكه العربيه السعوديه اتخذت
قرارها لتنويع مصادرها
لتكون مصلحتها اولا في سياستها التي تدير
فيها نقطه وتحالفها 2016 تحالف مهم ظهر
للاسواق وهو اقوى تحالف اقتصادي الان
في يبدو كمؤشرات لسيدها في الطريق الصحيح
كل عام وانت بالف خير وشكرا لوجودك معنا
كنت معنا من الخبر الاستاذ نايف الدندني
المحلل الاقتصادي تحياتي
الان الى دبي وفقره الاقتصاد مع الزميله
ناصر الطيبي ناصر مساء الخير كل عام وانت
بخير اليك